laisse moi je vois des trucs
t'as du bol moi je bouffe tout ce que je
peux jouer à 100 au kilo 350 tu te
fatigues le coeur kevin qu'est ce qui
dit tout ça le papa 70 à 2 coups pour le
moment j'adore kevin sale manie
montpetit dindonneau avec mon petit
coeur
je préfère rouler les paniques entière
je m'appelle bouboule il faut que ça
roule joker hambourg
c'est quoi ce bordel ici bas comment
maintien rocco comme l'acteur italien
rocco siffredi tu connais non monsieur
très bons acteurs comme ça les commandes
auxquelles il s'écroule
tellement 1 bat patrick ça fait quoi
faire avec bolt si tu veux devenir
commando tu arrêtes de bouffer cette
merde
j'aime tes caresses keaton désert il a
perdu du poids il faut se rendre à
l'évidence l'entraînement comment
d'autres cabines il fait du bien
mapou je m'appelle pour me